ar15.com is one of the most popular gun
forums
on the internet but this week godaddy
which is not supposed to be policing
content they're not your mom they
provide internet hosting services
took the remarkable step of yanking
ar15.com offline
so we asked godaddy today why and they
told us this what we received
a complaint regarding certain content on
ar15.com our team investigated the
content in question
and confirmed it violated our terms of
service because it quote incited
violence
whatever that means ar15.com is now back
online with the new hosting provider but
it's a moment that we should pause and
think about
with pete brannell he's the chairman of
the second adventure group the owner of
ar15.com
as well as the guy who runs brownells
which if you're a sportsman you know
well
we're happy to have him on snipe thanks
so much for joining us so thank you
sure in what world does godaddy have the
right to end
your ability to produce content i didn't
know that they could do that or did
right right it was a surprise to us that
that was the provider that we used that
pulled us off the website they're a
registrar for those who don't know them
and that's really the phone book for uh
when you type that into your browser it
directs you to our servers and they're
the ones that said we no longer want
you because you uh apparently have
violated one of their policies which is
patently false i mean it goes without
saying that it's a lie
and whatever you know they didn't
explain the standard i mean i we don't
even take that seriously
the reason that this is a chilling
moment and we wanted to hear directly
from you
is that it it's clearly a vision of the
future where
you're not allowed to express your views
on the second amendment even much less
exercise are you worried we are worried
about this
specific specifically with this
administration who has a
probably the worst uh policy or planks
that are coming in
on being restrict very restrictive on
firearm ownership a much drastic
or different view of how individual
ownership should be
regulated and registered in the united
states and if
if our voice is silenced or a half of
the argument is not even considered or
being allowed to speak in america today
that should be troubling for everybody
not just pro second amendment
individuals but everybody out there in
america should stand up and say wait a
second
this is not what our foundation of our
country was built on
and when it comes to a civil liberty
like the right to own firearms as
individual
you should all stand up and take note
specifically with
uh not having a voice to talk to each
other and raise awareness some of the
issues are definitely coming at us right
now
yeah i mean did you ever you're from
this country did you ever imagine
that big companies wholly outside
regulation by congress apparently could
just kind of eliminate the first and
second amendments and there's nothing
you can do about it
no it's very uh orwellian in its
approach it's one of those things that
you read about when you're in the 1950s
and 60s with those books that you read
in high school
and it becomes one of those things you
just can't believe it's the america that
you grew up in as you're living in right
now and i think
regardless of where you stand
politically we should all
we should all take pause and make sure
that we truly consider what kind of
rhetoric is going around and what kind
of controls we're giving to a few
when we start talking about uh being
able to communicate to each other
i just free speech it's america i just
read a new a news story that said
podcasts are problematic because they're
a loophole
in social controls it's hard to censor a
podcast how long before private
conversations will be considered a
loophole seriously right right when did
we yeah when did free speech become
something that
the government needs to put a uh
commission on
and and tell you what you can and cannot
say there are some restrictions but i
thought we were a free america here
i thought so too peter now the great
people now brownells great to see you
tonight thank you
thank you sir